what we're going to talk about in this
video is the effect of price controls on
changing how the surplus the total
surplus is reallocated between consumers
and producers and we already touch on
this in other videos the video on rent
control the video on minimum wages and
so this is to make sure that we are
taking away some of the big ideas so
right over here I have my classic demand
and supply curves for say the rental
market at a high price
the quantity demanded is low and the
quantity that people would be willing to
supply is quite high and at a low price
the quantity that people would be
willing to supply is low while the
quantity demanded would be quite high
and we've seen from many videos so far
in our journey through economics that we
have our equilibrium price in our
equilibrium quantity where these two
curves or lines intersect so I'll call
this Q sub zero and this is price Sub
Zero but let's say for whatever reason
city officials in this city where that
this rental market that this chart
describes the rental market for and they
decide that P Sub Zero is too high that
their voters are complaining that rents
are too high in the market and so the
city decides to put in a price control
and in this case they try to implement a
price ceiling so they say look the price
of rent per square foot per month cannot
go above this level right over here so
this is the price ceiling price ceiling
right over there now what's going to
happen here well if this is the price
ceiling then right over here
this is the total amount of square
footage the quantity of my guest square
footage that is being willing that
people are willing to supply that I
guess you could say landlords or
building owners are willing to supply
but at this price you have a much higher
quantity that is being demanded so this
is right over here is the quantity
demanded and when the quantity demand
price is higher than the quantity
supplied well then you have a shortage
so this right over here is describing a
shortage and we talked about that in
other videos but let's think about
what's happening to the total surplus so
when we let the market just get to an
equilibrium price in quantity the total
surplus actually let me just draw
separately the consumer and the producer
surplus so this was the consumer surplus
right over here before the government
intervention and then this is the
producer surplus we've talked about this
in other videos but now what happens
when we have this price control well
this is the quantity supplied now all of
a sudden the total surplus shrinks the
total surplus is now being depicted by
this white trapezoid and also think
about how things have shifted so one
thing that you see clearly what is the
producer surplus now the producer
surplus is only this little yellow try
or this little I don't know my colors
this little blue triangle at the bottom
so you see very clearly that all
producers suffer here all producers all
producers suffer now you might say well
of course this is a rent control but
surely the consumers will benefit here
well it isn't the case it is the case
that some consumers the ones that are
able to get into a unit they might
benefit so this right over here some
demanders or you could say some
consumers consumers benefit but not all
of the consumers benefit in fact you
have a shortage now before you had more
people who were able to get housing now
these folks are not going to get the
housing and as in all of economics you
should take a grain of salt in any type
of oversimplified model like this or
simplified this is actually a very
useful model for thinking about certain
things because even these consumers that
are benefitting according to this model
for these consumers it looks like their
surplus has grown or if you're if you're
this kind of marginal renter right over
here let me draw it over here if you
were the marginal renter that was before
getting this much benefit now you're
able to get that plus all of that but
think about the things that this model
is not capturing what's the incentive
for the landlord now would they want to
invest in the building as much would
they or they will they maybe let the
building kind of suffer a little bit and
there's also particular quirks for how
rent control is implemented that might
also change behavior so always keep in
mind that with what's not captured by
the model but in broad brush terms you
put in a price control in this case you
put in a price ceiling you're going to
create a shortage all the producers are
going to suffer some of the consumers
benefit according to this model but not
all of them because not all of them are
go now going to be able to get a place
to rent now let's move over to another
market let's say the corn market and
let's say once again we have our
equilibrium price and our equilibrium
quantity so price of equilibrium and
this is our quantity sub equilibrium but
let's say in this situation the
government let's say the farmer the corn
farmers are able to organize and they're
able to lobby the government and say hey
we really suffer when there's low corn
prices so where you want to institute a
price control we want you to institute a
price control we want a price floor so
the government says ok corn farmers you
seem to be pretty serious about it so we
are going to institute a price floor so
the price cannot go below this level so
this is a price floor well what's going
to happen now well let's think about the
quantity demanded and the quantity
supplied so that right over there is the
quantity demanded we see wherein the
price intersects the demand curve and
this right over here is a quantity
supplied where we're intersecting the
supply curve quantity supplied so in
this situation your demand is less the
quantity demanded is less than the
quantity supplied so in this case you
have a surplus the farmers would want to
produce more than people would want at
that price and I was thinking what
happens to that's total surplus and in
particular the consumer and the producer
surpluses so in the old world
this was the consumer
surplus and this right over here is the
producer surplus in the new world the
total surplus shrinks the sum of the two
we're now talking about this the area of
this trapezoid right over here this
sideways trapezoid and you see that all
consumers suffer because now the
consumer surplus has been shrunk right
over the consumer surpluses right over
here there's consumers who are now not
even consuming corn and even the ones
that are consuming corn before let's say
this marginal consumer right over here
was getting all of this benefit now they
are getting a smaller benefit so we
could say all all consumers suffer now
what about the producers well the
producers who are able to sell their
corn definitely get a benefit so if you
were this marginal producer right over
here your your surplus right over here
would have been like that but now you
get even a higher price for it and so
one way to think about it is some
producers some producers for Shore
benefit according to this model so let
me write that
so some producers producers benefit but
it's important to realize once again
that not all of the producers benefit
because once again we have a surplus if
it's implemented this way well you might
have a lot of farmers who aren't even
able to sell their corn to that at that
price so it's an interesting thing to
think about you should always take
models with a grain of salt but it is a
pretty interesting framework where
governments often will try to do some
type of knee-jerk solution to try to
make something look good or feel good to
their constituents but the end effect is
that people might suffer more than they
expect it might cause a shortage when
you put a price ceiling or it might
cause a surplus when you have a price
floor